it looks like DOMA the Defense of
Marriage Act could be on the way out
obviously President Obama has done a lot
of good stuff when it comes to gay
marriage and marriage equality that's
what we're told we should call it but
because of the Fifth Amendment which is
equal protection under the law they are
now saying that dome is really
indefensible and Obama is probably not
going to defend it all adds up I have a
feeling that this panel is pretty much
okay with that I'm super gay and am very
excited I would like to you know be a
human and have the right a bit basic
rights I loved it I circled this one
part for that for the house brief it
said gays and lesbians are one of the
most influential best-connected best
funded and best organized interest
groups in modern politics and have
attained more legislative victories
political power and popular favor and
less time than virtually any other group
in American history the house brief says
and I'm like yes uh with still no rights
yeah so if we could just get that
movement uh that would be fantastic all
of this is like you know pomp and
circumstance of a socratic yeah what is
someone last election cycle said the
game the game money is the new Hollywood
money that's what they that's what they
were saying what do you think about this
where it's time right i mean is there
anything to even debate here it's
ridiculous it's ridiculous that we were
in the 21st century and we are
discussing this uh that uh that it's a
basic civil rights issue and yet we know
was it alabama just passed the 13th
amendment yeah so you know could be a
while still yeah like you see come out
till tomorrow so it could be flipped
again but yeah so it's it astounds me
that you know what it is if there's a
section of our society our culture that
this white male established elite that
really really wants to keep it in 1952
once the country to be there and stay
there and and that's when they were in
charge and things are moving on and it
makes them nervous and so they're doing
everything they can to slow it down and
to end to end to demonize every bit of
the population that doesn't stand
with them so it's um so true it is about
time and I just I just hope hope it
finally finally happens now Fred i know
this is causes obviously dear and near
to your heart and you've been fighting
this thing from the inside so give us a
little sort of the insider steps of how
you think this is now gonna play out
well you know this goes back to the
seventies when we were getting beat up
and they were trying to ban gay teachers
in california and other states and we've
progressed to this unbelievable position
where we are now at the united states
supreme court thanks to Chad Griffin and
a few other tremendous leaders with a
lawsuit on two fronts one to try and
overturn proposition 8 which banned gay
marriage in California and now I'm DOMA
which is this was put in and signed by
democratic president bill clinton is is
completely oh now come out and opposed
it is going to be definitely turned out
as will the Supreme Court I think I'm
positive actually overturn prop 8 and go
along with that decision we just 14
states in November which is unbelievable
and now for the first time the argument
they use the opponent's used against
same-sex marriage was that the public is
against it well they're not now in four
states last November they passed it so I
think that proposition 8 will rule um
the overturning a proposition 8 and we
will discontinue for it and and there's
cases moving forward which will make
marriage equality the law of the land
and what a message that sends to younger
people who struggle I had a terrible
time growing up gay I was just I I no
self-esteem I was embarrassed I was I
mean it was a very difficult road for me
and I had a lot better than most and and
kids are suffering today and we see the
suicides teenage suicides we need to
make everyone in this country equal yeah
I mean you hit on a lot of points there
but I think one of the main things is
that well I think what's happened in the
last year or two is that we've learned
that the arguments against gay marriage
are completely insane unity they always
say when you're gonna destroy
traditional marriage I don't think that
there's one study that is proven where
you brought in gay people to be allowed
to be as regular and boring as straight
people that suddenly straight marriages
are crumbling or that they said if you
get rid of Don't Ask Don't Tell the
military is gonna suffer it's been over
a year now I don't think there's been
one
instance and I'm if I'm wrong please
correct me that Don't Ask Don't Tell
being flipped has done anything David
critic in this was the Pope yeah it was
not there for long but he said by the
eve of the Spanish boat when they voted
to allow same-sex marriage he said that
the gay marriage was insidious and
dangerous this was three years ago in
the height of the priest abuse scandal
I'm thinking what about that why doesn't
he take on that issue instead of
attacking poor people who are innocent
and just want to be happy and and marry
the person that they love and divorce
rate is about like fifty six percent
like they're doing it so well so I feel
like what is yes it's it's completely
it's completely insane I have to say
those on a positive note i do so much
traveling for stand up I mean to like
parts of the country where you're like
was good how was this gonna go no one
blinks no one has a problem with it when
I start talking about politics there's a
problem but what I literally talked
about like gay marriage and I start my
like gay marriage joke it's like people
are clapping but like rural counties
like across the country so it's been
super positive and I think and the
Supreme Court historically has never
really taken on such big social issues
unless until like the tide is turned
they did that with uh you know
interracial marriage and so I don't know
it seems really positive which that's
fine because I think that you know
Supreme Court justices are there for
life so that they can make brave choices
but as you said they always wait until
it's a past the tipping point the middle
we did this and don't forget bonobos
calm is the official outfitter of the
Ruben report enter code Ruben report for
twenty percent off your first purchase